welcome to film courage this is episode
160 I'm Karen warden and I'm David
Brannon our guest today or independent
film marketing and publicity specialist
and now author Cherie candler and
filmmaker author founder of hybrid
cinema John Reese you may remember
sherry and John from prior shows most
recently they appeared alongside Jeffrey
winner of the film collaborative
regarding their team effort with the
film collaborative on selling your film
without selling your soul recently John
launched the distribution company hybrid
cinema in order to help filmmakers
navigate the ever-changing world of film
distribution and marketing the film
Joffrey Mavericks of American dance is
hybrids second full release of the film
following the graffiti documentary bomb
it and let's see here I don't be playing
a clip in just a moment you know but let
me let me talk about the film Joffrey
Mavericks of American dance is written
and directed by Bob Hercules sherry can
learn yes I was going to say that that's
a probably fulfillments probably the
greatest name in you know in filmmaking
history Bob hurt you yeah that's love
that one sherry caylor's involved with
marketing partnerships and community
outreach regarding the film we are proud
to say that this is the fourth time that
sherry and John have been on film
courage these to share the record for
most appearances on our show with that
please welcome via telephone sherry
candler and in person John Reese welcome
guys welcome thanks for having us here
yeah thanks for being here sure hi there
we go we have Siri we had a little drama
by my name there for some reason the
number just wouldn't connect to sherry
so we're glad that you called us the
radio God yeah testing us you know we
love being able to connect people here
on the show we always try to bring
people together so we encourage you
listening to connect with John at John
you know at John Reese calm as well as
on Twitter John underscore Reese and
also sherry sherry candler calm and
sherry candler on twitter and if you're
listening live you'd like to connect
with us you can do so at film courage or
hashtag film courage so something we've
never really heard from the two of you
whether it be this show or anywhere else
is a snapshot of the standard day in the
life of sherry can lure and John Reese
that's right okay so let's without okay
who wants the start here we're gonna
ladies first let's start with you please
give us a highlight starting with the
moment you wake up what is the day in
the life of sherry camera okay um well
about a year and a half ago i got an
android which is kind of like the curse
of my life now because I sleep with it
next to the bed so before I even get up
I'm already checking email Facebook and
Twitter just to see what I have phasing
before I even get out of bed sometimes I
even answer stuff while i'm still laying
there if it's quick so i haven't even
turned the computer on or sat down at
the desk or anything I try not to do
that in the middle of the night I have
heard of people not being able to sleep
at 2am so they fiddle around with their
phone I try not to do that because I
that will wake me up and i'll be up so I
I don't do that but um probably don't
turn off the computer until eleven
o'clock at night so so I'm usually still
up late doing whatever until six or
seven in the morning before I check it
again um you know then start off the day
turning on the computer and coming back
and thinking about what what what do I
have to post this morning on facebook
what do I need I need to check you know
what's going on on Twitter overnight for
any European or Asian audiences that
might have caught on to something that
we did checked all the google alerts to
see if any interesting stories come up
that I should be posting about or
something that I could blog about later
I try to think that we used to week or
two in advance of what I'm going to be
blogging about as far as the fillmore
for myself or for any other project that
I'm working on some have a lot of things
that are in draft that I want to add to
later and I'll start off with one or two
sentences to remind me of where I was
trying to go at this story and and come
back and add things to it I also
searched around on the internet see if I
can find any photos or videos that I can
link to within this
story that will make it more you know
rich story bring it to life um I don't
know I mean that's sort of a lot of my
day I take conference calls with other
people talking about you know they
handle other aspects of the release so
finding out have we got any new dates
added what's coming up in the next week
you know the publicists might have a
story that's going to be placed and she
needs a couple of references from people
who are in the cast of the film or
something like that and do we need to
make a connection with them and arrange
that with their schedule you know are
there any requests that for posters or
anything like that usually the Booker's
are handling those and getting that out
but just you know keeping an eye on
what's going on and is everybody doing
what they're supposed to do because
sometimes I get emails back go directly
that the book was relying in touch with
the people who are hosting it directly
so sometimes I get those but not very
often um you know John and I talk
probably once a day but every few days
for sure on email all the time but
sometimes on the phone you know just
it's it's constant work it's constantly
something needing to be written or
something needing to be found and posted
interacting with people on the facebook
channel if they've seen what i posted
that day i'll give it like 15 or 20
minutes because some of them are really
quick about their content i'm going back
and seeing you know what was the
reaction so far i try not to be so
hair-trigger of oh gosh we haven't
gotten a comment in 15 minutes you know
that's not probably not realistic but
you know checking around to see if
there's anything that needs needs
attention and then I also do minimize
things for a few hours just so I can
concentrate on writing or researching or
doing other work so I'm not constantly
thinking about I need to you know
respond to that or check on it right
away yeah that's I mean that's basically
that goes on all day and thinking about
even weeks ahead of time you know should
I need to do some research in a certain
area of the town where I know we're
going to have a screening so i can send
emails to the directors of those schools
and let them know that the screening is
happening and here's the details and
here's the trailer in case
you haven't heard about it and and then
if we get emails back asking more
information or wanting us to send them
postcards answering that kind of
correspondent yeah so that's what sort
of goes on in my day Wow constantly
keeping in touch it sounds like mm-hmm
for John for me yeah I try not to look
at my phone when I wake up I think it
would be too depressing because it's
like in the morning there's usually
especially in the fall when we're in the
thick of things they're probably 200
emails came in like since I turned off
the computer so it's kind of like too
daunting you know so i usually make a
cup of coffee for my wife wake my kids
up put the dogs out drive my kids to
school and then then after that when I'm
then I start the day and it's usually it
all depends on what's happening you know
which part of the release were in so you
know if we're just getting the site up a
lot of it is dealing with the website
designer and dealing with and also for
early in the release talking about the
bookers about what the strategy is going
to be talking to Sherri about what the
marketing strategy is going to be
talking to the publicist you know it's
like it's a lot of meetings like that
just kind of a lot of it it's very
similar in a sense and this is why you
know going back to the producer of
marketing distribution I really feel
it's it feels very I've produced films
before and it's very much like being a
producer you're managing a lot of
different aspects of the release and
you're also and reaching out to people
and engaging people and so recently we
just closed the Canadian deal for the
film I'm reaching out the ford sales
representatives so it's writing emails
to them and keeping in touch with them
and you know kind of like we're wrapping
up the the Booker's on the film so we're
transitioning into keeping that on in
our office and how that's going to
transition in our office and you know we
have new york coming up so sherry and i
were just talking about like oh what
else can we do to promote that makes
financial sense to promote the the
theatrical release of new york so it's
all every week but it's always
communicating with people and but i
probably do more email the than social
media is sherry always is on my case
about and just because it's like that's
kind of like it's more it's cuz I in a
sense and more
would say I'm more managing than
engaging with fans which I think
Cherie's doing more directly is my
impression it so I have if you anyway
that's I guess would it be and then you
know because the Joffrey is not and I
think this is also true with sherry but
I won't speak for her but it's not the
only thing in our life like I have other
clients that I talked to I am talking to
filmmakers about their projects to see
whether it makes sense for us to work
together and then I'm potentially
watching their films or talking to them
about what their strategies for their
film should be etc that kind of thing so
right and taking it in another direction
i have to say that it is a very
seductive thing to put a tweet out there
or a post on facebook and then get that
instant reaction back and people have
joked about the fact that down the line
we may need you know treatment centers
for social media addiction because it is
of I mean I I say that jokingly but it
is a very you know we don't have a phone
for that reason because it is very
seductive to put that out there and then
I see it in my 12 year old daughter I
mean I actually have to limit her time
and it's just kind of like you're done
you know it's like and it's like and
it's like it's almost withdrawal you
know and it's like it I think it's you
know so there are ya I I'm probably the
opposite I you know anyway I so anyway
alright more efficient to the to the
work that we do for other people we also
have to keep up our own names brands
right things that are independent that
speaking you know alright you you're
running a business you're also running
things for other clients right now and
for yourself you know and you're your
own like it's like you know both cherry
and I speak a lot and it's like right
you know the logistics of that you know
it takes that's a lot a lot so it's like
kind of like running that all of that
stuff is like it's you know it's 12 hour
it's i would say on average it's 10
hours to 12 hours a day and then when
it's busy it's like 16 hours a day you
know and would you concur with that
sherry yes i say 12 is probably true you
know that that's something i working for
yourself you don't have to do the 925 so
you could take an hour off and go to the
gym or whatever but that just means an
hour after you eat dinner
you're back on the computer you're
making up the time later on in the
evening when most people who have
nine-to-five jobs have gone home so it's
I think that the time balances out
during the day or probably even more so
but you can take these breaks in the
daytime that other people who are
employed those companies can't and i
would i would say that this most people
listening to the show who are
independent filmmakers or artists would
probably be nodding their heads I mean
it's like a tough it's a lot of work
doing what we all do it's like it's
never it's like it's never ending but
that's again what you sign up for in a
sense you know we dinner behind
computers as well you know I mean but
you both have your pulse on independent
film and on the independent film success
stories and we just wanted to kind of
start this show just just you know maybe
maybe you guys can both highlight some
of the big success success stories we've
seen in independent film over the last
two years we're just looking to to kind
of draw some some inspiration here um
all right yeah you know I wrote it to me
ride the divide and which is one of the
film's I wrote about in selling your
film without selling your soul to me
that's a big success story I mean they
were financially successful they've met
their goals you know they've kind of
like launched into a new kind of career
path for themselves that kind of like
they use the model of that film to
perpetuate that model they continue to
make films they get their films out
there simultaneously you know they they
seem to have like made it work and I
just hats off to those guys and I'll
throw another one out you know I think
Gregory Bane is pursuing a very
successful model I was you know I always
put out a shout for craigory i think but
i think and i haven't he's one person i
haven't really written about much but i
really like like what Gregg is is doing
out there in the space and who would you
add sir well I think that it depends on
what we're talking about when we say
success you know are we taking talking
about box office success are we talking
about overall profit success which
nobody really does know that number so I
think that it's difficult to to gauge
what's considered to visit success when
you get when your film is not profitable
but you get more work yourself yeah I so
I think that is
successful people who is you know
unclear as to how successful their film
was Lena Dunham would be a success story
out of Tiny Furniture the reefs would be
a success story out of pariah I don't
know how financially successful those
songs were but for those two women they
were very successful films that led to
bigger career move for them you know I
think I like what Ava Duvernay is doing
she she has she came from a publicist
background she's now a director of a
film who that one at Sundance she's
distributing it on her you know through
her company that's also partnered up
with a lot of the black film festivals
across the United States to put not only
her work out but a lot of other work out
so I think that's a success of meeting
that goal I don't know if we're only
talking to financial success I don't
know yeah I didn't tell you no no all
the numbers behind and hats off to
sherry for saying because usually
whenever I presented with that question
I always start off with like what do you
mean by success and to me success is
meeting our goals whatever the goals
happen to be you know and so like I
don't know exactly how Gregory Baines
financials work out but I know he's
making a career for himself in the
manner that he wants to as an
independent filmmaker and to me that's
successful so you know and so and he's
pursuing this new path you know he's not
you know he's not just thinking as to
what we were talking about earlier which
is like oh I'm gonna get in festival and
that's going to launch my career and
blood he's like rejected all that or
doesn't that doesn't count on any of
that he's pursuing his own path and
making a success for himself you know
out of using a variety of the new tools
that are available of those examples of
the the handful that you gave what were
the key components I mean they all have
very different niches and and
demographics that they're appealing to
what were the the key components that
you know brought them those success
stories I mean I think the main thing is
that each of them have a vision and a
passion and they've stuck to it you know
that's what I would say is that you know
the key component
and you know a you know I for my two
examples is to not be dependent on
others and not be dependent on the old
system to have to garner success from
you know so that's what you know but I
you know I know that yeah so that's what
I was okay anything to add cherry why we
can say that probably my tiny furniture
and pariah were completely dependent on
having powerful champions so I mean if
that's one of your goals and that's what
you need to do is your idea of success
is going to be less revenue driven than
it is defying very powerful people who
want to champion you and can make things
happen it doesn't happen probably for
the majority of people but for some
people that it does happen to you in it
and both of those films started out in
very prestigious festivals they were
good films reviewed well picked up done
all them usually sought i don't know
like i said i don't know how financially
successful they were but for both of
those women if their goal was to be
pushed ahead in their career they got it
that was the method that goal for those
you know to continue to expand on this
you know filmmakers AG foresman wrote in
and he would love to hear a little bit
more about your personal successes in
the lessons that you've learned along
the way and I guess we'll direct that
towards you share you know that because
you know you've had the opportunity to
work with filmmakers behind the scenes
you know what what what if you talk a
little bit about those successes and
about the lessons you've learned along
the way Wow um I mean I'm always
striving for more personal success I
guess the whole fact that I'm on so
encouraged gives me some feeling of
satisfied no one knew who i was at all I
mean I'm literally somebody who started
from zero and and worked for what
whatever I have now is only the process
of working hard making some influential
friends proving my worth to them
actually working on projects that that
got some notoriety notability you know
we're successful in their own way helps
lead to my success all
constantly studying and keeping up with
whatever is trending you know whatever
thing is on the horizon and trying to
figure out how does that fit into a
helpful tool for what we're doing and
it's constantly changing so it's not
like something I go yet I'm I'm an
expert in this and I don't need anything
I don't need to learn any more about it
you're constantly learning you're
constantly spending that time so there's
the professional development that helps
in your success and then there's the
practical development of actually going
out and putting them into practice and
seeing what works what doesn't why you
know even when it fails thinking why why
does this to work for that and it
doesn't work for this and what did work
what can you change so professionally I
guess that's what I've learned is to if
you get as much out of it that you put
into it and also being helpful is really
important like people really respond to
that way more than hoarding information
than being secretive or being selective
constantly about who you speak to I am
pretty open as far as as talking to lots
of different people from lots of
different backgrounds and and getting
inspiration and ideas even from a lot of
times outside of the filmmaking
community and trying to apply it in some
way that I think is useful for what I do
John I know you you advocate the 50-50
rule meaning you know if you have a
hundred thousand dollars if that's your
budget then then half of that should go
toward making the film and half of that
should go towards marketing distribution
you know when your approach i mean how
many filmmakers do you see that actually
set down set aside a reasonable a
reasonable amount of money where they
have to market and distribute their
films are you seeing that yet
unfortunately no a little bit more and
more not as much as i would like to see
out there you know and you know there
are some filmmakers that you know are
you know i'm working with one now it's
like well we're shooting our film we
need to raise more money but it's like
there's very few people that do it an
inception
and I'm always kind of saying you know
okay so you have a hundred thousand
dollars really slot 50 of that away for
audience engagement which I view is all
distribution of marketing like spotting
that away you know because I just that
you'll be in such better shape than if
you just spend all your money on on
making the film and then you come to
someone like me or anyone and say I have
I'm done you know I have no more
resources and because basically the that
world of d Reese and Lena Dunham it's
like the one percent of one percent you
know end up with those kind of deals and
they still exist in the problem with
those deals is that then it kind of
reinforces the myth the mythology of the
old system that used to be more robust
for filmmakers and when there were fewer
filmmakers and a higher percentage of
filmmakers you know got some financial
success out of that old festival
acquisition system and so that mythology
is refreshed every time something like
that happens but what most filmmakers
don't still seem to understand is that
only really for one percent max you know
there's 45 35 to 45 5,000 new feature
films every year 600 end up in the
festival circuit as a whole 200 end up
in Sundance maybe on a great year 40 end
up with some sort of decent financial
deal and one will end up with a theory
scenario every two years you know sherry
when these filmmakers approached you I
you know I sorry to be so I don't mean
to be so no no I sometimes I feel like
I'm so depressing and like you know
paternalistic in like you have my finger
wagging out there and just party cuz we
were talking about the earlier but it's
just kind of like you know lets you know
the world's there you're just let me put
in a more positive spin you're so much
better off if you plan for something
else like if you work on this is what we
do in the ifp filmmaker labs like okay
so maybe that will happen to you great
okay maybe that will happen so it
because they're having to diri who had
pariah in the labs but everyone else
know and that's why also Sundance set up
Sundance artist services because they
even saw that most of their filmmakers
didn't end up like dear Olympus pariah
or whoever you know Lena did most of the
filmmakers that are even at Sundance
end up that way so they set up a system
to help those filmmaker so you
filmmakers out there need to think and
help yourself like really kind of think
about I'm making this film what do I
want from it and how am I going to
achieve that if no one else is going to
give that to me which and most likely is
not going to happen
I think the realism is important instead
of just kind of Oh follow your bliss and
and all that and and and the money will
come I think that the realism is
important so no I don't think that
that's that you're being a downer yeah
you know and when John says we spoke you
know we did it we did our pre interview
with John before we came to the studio
so we got John all warmed up when you
hear them reference he's referencing are
outside the studio video that we've
already done and sherry you know that
just makes me wonder this whole kind of
scenario is that what you often face is
that filmmakers essentially have have
have run it run through all their money
and yet they're coming to you and saying
like hey sherry we have no money but can
you help us you know get this movie out
there get this movie scene and help us
make money is that is that what your
face quite often with four or five
emails a week of that situation and I
and I you know I I had to think besides
maybe I try not to just delete those
emails I always try to go back to them
with something even though it's you know
it's almost always a sorry can't help
you um here's I give them the idea okay
you don't have any money everything that
you need to know about how to do this is
free on the internet now you have to
spend time because you didn't spend
money you don't have money to spend and
I'm not going to do that I have already
spent my time and I figured that that is
valuable so now that's what I sell so
when you come to me and you tell me I'd
like you to take all the time that you
spent and work for me for free or work
for me for maybe a percentage of
whatever I can get no that's not a try I
don't want to be an owner in your film
I'm not going to do that if you can find
somebody else do that great but I'm not
going to do that but I can point you in
directions of places where you can go
and educate yourself I would I have a
place I have a place to the point i have
a place to point them they can go to
John Reese com store / door and I
actually have and i actually have sales
hot dog sales because i'm going to be at
hot doctor there's hotdogs sales on
think outside the box office and selling
your film without selling your soul in
various combinations and there for like
20 bucks you can get both books you know
and read those you know and for twenty
bucks what's the promo code you ever
know there's no protocol just like it's
the height for the next month it's the
hot dog special it's like they're you
know prices / so 20 bucks for two books
you know and you know you spend a month
reading those and you'll you know and I
get filmmakers all the time it's like I
release my film with your book you know
it's like right good job I'm happy I you
know it's like you know and um you know
so it's like you know great and then
some people times people come to me and
Sheree to want more help and then then
obviously we have to charge them for
that but you know but you can the
information is out there you can do what
we did if you have no money you know the
there are possibilities I hate to say
that because i don't want filmmakers
just still ending up with no money you
know and you know i want more filmmakers
like this one film that i'm working with
now where they don't even there they're
barely they're not even shooting yet and
they you know it's like well what are we
going to start audience engagement it's
like okay we'll get going soon you know
it's like and and that's great you know
it's like those are I want more of those
but unfortunately there's that it's
still a small little small piece of
honey in hopefully eventually ill 10
years I mean we're in a transitional
period hopefully within five to 10 years
everyone will be thinking in this way
mm-hmm sherry how many filmmakers can
you name right now that have at least
15,000 fans on Facebook and does this
matter I don't know tournament because
I've always contended that 15,000 fans
on Facebook looks really great how many
of them actually are going to do
anything for you that's your real number
it doesn't take very much at all for
people to click like and then never come
back and you fall out of their feet and
you can't count on them probably a
better gauge is how many people have
15,000 email addresses that they can
directly contact when they need to
because those people have actually given
you permission to contact them people
who just click like on your Facebook
page there's really no way to contact
them outside of your facebook page and
if they're not visiting you constantly
or you don't continue to show up in
their in their newsfeed after a while
they forget that they ever liked your
page and they don't keep up with what's
going on there
I don't like to use Facebook as a gauge
of how many fans you have I know a lot
of distributors do that though so it's
worth it if you can get people to click
like but just know that that's not an
automatic people to count on it
certainly not automatic sales you can
say at 15,000 fans times twenty dollars
DVD how much is that maybe they're not
all going to buy so that doesn't really
it's not that much of a gauge to tell
you mean it looks good but I can I don't
think hey sorry Jerry can I jump in a
little bit sure yeah so I was just going
to say that um you know I think I
totally agree with everything cherry
saying and I think it's all it is truly
about engagement like if you want to see
someone who really kind of works the
system well and kind of engage as well
as a filmmaker I always refer people to
EDD Byrnes you know because he and he
actually is able to he cultivates his
audience he's on there all the time he
responds to people constantly and so
that when he says my films coming out
and please go to iTunes and help me get
into the top 10 those people are loyal
to him because they're engaged and I
hats off to him because he has a really
great talent at that and granted he you
know had some cred before head but you
know he's built you know and so he was
already a name but he did kind of like
he's he hasn't just taken that celebrity
and just slept on it you know I done
nothing what he's really worked hard to
develop that audience and he's gone back
talk about like what we were talking
about earlier where you're just he
stopped working the studio system he
started going back to his roots of
making films for fifteen thousand
dollars and taking them straight to his
fans and he's doing a great job with it
he just said the system doesn't work
anymore i spend years developing films
that never get off the ground and i'm
just going to go back to brothers
McMullen what i did with brothers oh
come on i'm going to make a film and i
know i'm i'm responsible for
distribution marketing no one's going to
do that for me i have to plan for that
and i'm going to engage my fans i'm
going to make films one film a year on
the small budget and we're going to take
it straight to people i can engage with
them and so and you'll see different
things that he does he tries different
things you know so it's it's good to
follow people so again I think Gregory
Bain is active zach is out that Zach
forsman who I think called it I think
he's interesting you know look at other
filmmakers King as
thing are you know look at filmmakers
who are really using the tools and
engaging with people you know and follow
them and use them as models and finish
line Tiffany Shlain Gregory bein I'll
say again you know it's like you know
there's you cut Greg you owe me dinner
or something um and uh so you know the
look at filmmakers who are out there
kind of like really communicating with
people and see how they do it and you
know see how that fits within your and
that's what I recommend to my students
at calarts who don't do you know it's
like you know look at people who are
doing what you want to do and you know
see how you fit in there and emulate in
Europe but in your own way is there and
it does also set my teeth on edge when
people go oh but ed burns he came and
Kevin Smith they came up through the
through the system of course it's easy
yes they're going to start off with more
fans than you are when you start from
zero but there's so many people who are
in that system who don't care about
connecting directly with their fans they
don't do that they have an agent they
have a talent manager they don't they
don't have to talk to people you know
that that's the attitude change with
those guys that's really important is
they do feel like that's important they
aren't going to be at the whim of you
know every faceless person who comes to
the box office in the next week you're
the flavor of the week you know and then
you're not they have a direct audience
they can go to and and and that will
support them that's a different mindset
than most people who work in the system
yeah like what Joe Wilson a vampire mob
said he said start with one person and
just build from there and in keeping
with that do you have a preference of
Facebook versus Twitter or again it's
the same animal but it's the level of
engagement okay just you have to do I
just recommend doing both no sin they're
just different you know sherry can talk
to this probably more than I can well I
would say facebook is hard to argue
against not using when they have 800
million users I mean to say you've got
to find some pity there who likes what
you do in some capacity it may not be
your only tool there may be other places
usually when they change their platform
every eight months and you have to write
you do everything to conform to their
Jesus Christ you shouldn't build your
whole audience on social media you
should you know you should also have
your own which is what sherry and I
preach a lot that okay use the existing
platform because that's where people are
but don't rely on those platforms to be
the sole places where your audience
lives you have to have your own sites so
that you have your own direct
relationship with your audience y are
independent filmmakers afraid to day and
date their films John why don't we start
with you um who uh I think it's kind of
like fearful of rights and rights
consequences I would think you know and
then fearful that they might think they
might get a theatrical and how that's
going to affect it I don't I are
filmmakers fearful day-and-date you
think we just don't just don't see it
though we don't we don't see it I have
to say it's really hard you know and so
it's like what is day indeed like in so
there I think there's different forms of
day and date and so like I prefer day
and month and so it's kind of like you
have to look at different you have to
again up some one of my other mantras is
every film is different so you have to
see what the release path for your film
is and so what makes sense for your film
and so you know if you do have some
theatrical possibilities then having
your DVD and or your or being on iTunes
it's going to be difficult because
certain theaters won't book you so
that's why i recommend will maybe having
a two-month theatrical window that's if
you're going to do theatrical which i'm
not a big huge fan of traditional
theatrical if you know i'm a much bigger
fan of events but you know it's I don't
you know because it's a I wouldn't maybe
they don't do I don't know why they
don't do it maybe they don't do because
it's a lot of right a lot of work to get
all those rights going at the same time
if you're doing it on your own you know
so that's and so it's sometimes better
to push it out but I do recommend though
having all try to get all your rights in
at least one release window so that the
publicity can kind of complement each
other so that you can make a bigger dent
in the media landscape so that's like
three a three to four month window I
would recommend
mmm you know and you know unless you
have a lot of resources that maybe you
can stretch it to six months yeah that's
what I'd say to that anything you want
to add sherry no I think that that you
know what John said is I think most
filmmakers are fearful they they still
do think that there's possibility of
getting some kind of a deal and they
don't want to ruin it by forging ahead
this is kind of going back to you when
you make a decision you kind of have to
stick with it if you know from the
beginning that you're planning on doing
some form of direct distribution the the
traditional distributions plan B not
plan a there's is it the other way you
know it's the other way around of
thinking that for sure i'm going to do
direct distribution and if it happens to
lead to some other distribution deal
coming through the door great if it
doesn't i haven't waited for anything
and i can tell you for a fact that
because i worked with you know prior was
in the labs that they were planning
something you know they were not
counting on that sale you know they had
other things in mind that they were
going to engage you know but then the
sale happened you know so i think
they're out you know there's hopeful
that that's going to happen you always
you know hope you're going to be that
one tenth of one percent you know you
hope you're going to be Donald Trump may
well maybe not personality wise but
maybe you know everyone hope so I you
know not everyone but many people hope
god I hope I'm a millionaire you know
but it's the same thing of thinking you
know or gotta help I'm a billionaire you
know yeah I want to be Mark Zuckerberg
and I want to be you know I want to have
a 500 billion dollar IPO but yeah
there's five people who get that you
know that's similar to what happened to
D Reese okay so but D Reese went in
thinking not that that's weak she had
they had another plan well yeah I mean
it's it's amazing especially when you
just go back to the numbers that that
you that you're throwing our way today
John if you're talking 35,000 films made
a year and you're talking 600 are going
to get you know some sort of attention
or a possible distribution deal and yet
no no no 600 on the festival circuit on
the circuit and then get them down what
what's the final number you said I think
you know in terms of the distribution
like 40 40 40 so we're talking and
that's a good year z I'm being too
generous you're talking 35,000 you're
talking down to 40
and yet what are we doing what why the
filmmakers keep on the same path you
know they get it gets so frustrating you
know by now that's the question
where every person that comes to me
believe they're going to be one of the
40 everyone it's just unbelievable and
it's good to have faith and passion and
belief in yourself but it's also good to
be realistic and to kind of under
there's a new world you know and that
you know that E is so funny because God
I think he I can say that yeah I
interviewed Yancey Strickler and he felt
filmmakers are the most entitled group
of artists ever that he encounters that
they feel like every that the world owes
them something and like a you know and
it's like he was kind of surprised by
that and sorry Yancey if i'm not but i
think i was able to say that on the
record and and and i find that a little
bit you know it's like you know and i
think it's because of that mythology in
the history and kind of like you know
hollywood and you know and it's like
you're and filmmakers are working
artists like all other working artists
you know and it's kind of like you're
you're it's almost blue collar in nature
you know it's like you work and you
create art and then you connect you try
it you have to go sell it you know you
have to go connect with people and no
one's gonna you know it's there's it
again it's a one percent of one percent
that are going to have something handed
to them on a platter you know and
speaking along these lines sherry our
film festivals are they really the first
place that filmmakers should be looking
to distribute their films or have their
film seen as that as that where we need
to be going well it depends on the
festival and it depends on if you're
thinking about it being your first place
for theatrical they're probably the
cheapest place for theatrical for you
instead of you know having to try and
make agreements with with booking
agencies or to go to theaters on their
own you don't have to do that the only
thing about it is you're at the mercy of
the festival picking you and paying you
know a small fee or a fee in general to
see what you get so you have to have two
of those plans either that you're going
to do the festival circuit which we
generally have
not done with Joffrey we have played
very few festivals and we just went to
theaters directly ourselves or that
you're going to you're going to you know
try your luck and see what happens there
and I mean definitely you're
piggybacking on the efforts that they
make to get people to buy tickets passes
to the festival that's one less thing
you have to do because at least people
are going to come to the festival now if
they come to your screening or not is
another situation and you have to to
rally people to come to see your film
instead of somebody else's but at least
they're already aware that this event is
happening in their town or within the
industry that's the other consideration
is what are you using the festival
circuit to do are you using it to
connect with the audience are using it
for industry attention because that's
going to determine which festivals
you're going to even apply to and try to
get into so i think you know just to
kind of like right you have to look at
your film look at what film festivals
might be appropriate to it and more
importantly how festivals fit into the
overall strategy of your film and some
films are not appropriate for festivals
it's just they don't you know put broad
comedies vessels in general there's a
few pestles that are comedy vessels but
most festivals don't cater to brought
comedies for instance and you have to
think about is this like a real festival
darling film that really makes sense to
go that route oars are there specific
vessels so for Joffrey we picked
specifically picked the top niche
Festival for that film and we went after
it to premiere there and we decided that
if we got that in which we end up doing
that that would launch our release and
that we would then use the publicity for
that to jumpstart the release and then
other festivals if we got other
festivals we would fold the men and we
deal with them on a case-by-case basis
and we've been in some other festivals
and frankly because we've we did make
the choice and we've kind of
quote-unquote suffered maybe a little
bit in a traditional festival release
because we've had to turn down to
prominent film festivals and then a
third very prominent like hot docs we
didn't get in because they said we
played too much he was going to play the
film and but you've played too much and
then we now have Canadian distribution
so we can't play Vancouver which we're
invited to and we couldn't do Seattle
because we had
long run in Seattle so we had but this
is what we made all these decisions in
like we are thinking oh should we play
it via Seattle well no we have a week
long run it's like why do even though
see how is a great festival and be
wonderful to be in it we had a strategy
in place and we adhere to that strategy
as far as like what would work best for
the release pass path of the film and
i'm just going to encourage filmmakers
to vessels are one part of your
distribution and part of your strategy
and to incorporate them with everything
else that you need to deal with you are
tuned in the film courage are this is
our last live episode and it's flying by
here in la talk radio from here on out
you'll be able to find our archives on
film curse calm as well as itunes we are
in studio with john reese and we are on
the line with sherry candler you can
follow them at john underscore recent at
sherry candler on twitter John you
release your book think outside the box
office in twenty ten i believe and i
think 2012 2009 it was ok well pow see
you know what kind of flies yeah people
were saying we can't believe film Kurds
been around for three years I can't
believe the book has been around for
this long as well and you've been
talking distribution since then how did
the opportunity sort of come about for
you to get into film distribution so I
guess well keep out like it comes about
for most filmmakers when you know we
were Tribeca trying to sell our film and
you know no one bought it so um you know
so it's just like you know it's like am
I gonna let my film what I thought was
my best filmed I know I'm gonna go out
and you know do with my self and
you know so excuse my language again and
you know and I didn't do it completely
myself and I do preach us if you can get
like we I worked with new video new
video picked up the DVD and some of the
digital rights erm had the other digital
rights you know and I had a you know I
had people that I was working with but
like the Thea was coordinated by me is
as it is with most filmmakers these days
in a contemporary fashion and so in
doing that then my producer executive
producer Jeff leave a hint he said I
should write about it because he hadn't
seen if they'll make her do what I was
doing before and so I talked to Scott
McCauley Scott said write some articles
started writing some articles and people
responded to them and I discovered I had
a talent for writing about a complex
system or this complex system in a very
practical matter of fact step-by-step
fashion and which I never knew I had
that skill before and people said write
a book and so since I often do what
people tell me to do I wrote a book so
and then that's you know it's kind of I
say that tongue in cheek but people
encouraged me to write it I kind of
thought about it I kind of thought you
know Ted hope frankly said look knowing
there is no book like this you'll be the
first one get your together and
write it and so I did and there we are
oh very nice Thank You Ted ho thanks dad
yeah real quickly we are running out of
time but with Joffrey where did you
begin with a film what was your strategy
and what did you do to engage the ballet
audience wow so I'll start with where we
started and then I'll pass it off to
sherry as far as like what we did to
engage the ballet audience so i started
with them frankly they they read the
book and came to me like about a year
ago just as a consulting client and so I
spoke to them and then you know the for
a little while and then they said well
you know maybe we want you to get more
involved and so I said well how about if
we write I write a distribution
marketing plan and I and I talked to
sherry sherry because I knew sherry like
ballet and cheer and I have been looking
for something to do together so you know
I said Jared you want to work on this
with me and so she said yes and so we
wrote that plan and then you know we are
hoping that they were going to engage us
in June and then but things happen so we
started actually in September and so
which is and then when you think about
starting in September for a launch in
January we are like going out of our
lines I mean and but we figured you know
it's like this is the best way to do the
film and you know it's a good film to do
something like this with and again do
not recommend this the filmmakers do not
give yourself only four months from
start of audience engagement like they
there was no audience engagement before
September at all and our launch of our
release was January so it was like the
fall I can't even remember was just like
a you know what almost like a haze of 16
hour days
and like there was no website there's no
facebook there's nothing it was like a
blank there's no trailer there's no
poster there was it was a blank slate
and so you know but it was it was a good
opportunity for us and for us to work
together as a good film that we felt had
an audience and you know and he even
said the executive producer Jo I said
like you get to chill get to try all
these things that you know like practice
what you preach and so it was you know
they've been very supportive and so you
know that's why we did it on that time
schedule and so I'll let Jerry take thee
which made Jerry's job of the audience
engagement that much more difficult you
know because of the short timeline right
um so I could have said well this is a
ballet fant Valley film for ballet fans
which in a way if you look at it as a
niche audience clearly it's a big niche
because ballet is worldwide and there's
always in the United States for sure
there's a ballet company in every state
and there's ballet schools almost in
every town so that still makes it very
wide if you're working with a modest
budget and I'm not saying that we you
know had a tiny budget we have a pretty
decent budget but it's still modest by
you know any any studio standard it's
blabble um so we have to be very careful
and very targeted about what we were
going to go after and how to spread it
out from there and you know how I always
say you've got to catch fire with some
small group first the ballet audience is
not small it's still too big so I'm
looking thinking okay so where do I go
how do I treat this down even further
who would be the most interested in
seeing a film about the Joffrey Ballet
former dancers of the Joffrey maybe um
that would probably be the best group to
start with there are numerous they're
spread out all over the country in the
world often they're in high-level
positions at other companies and ballet
companies these are their artistic
directors or their ballet masters or
sometimes they're easy to find for the
most part not that I I wasn't given a
database list with everybody's contact
details I had to do that I had to put it
support where we are finally eventually
given
12 people but like two months after we
started well here's the list that you
guys for two months ago and that's not
the producers that's actually from the
Joffrey and the one thing i will say i'm
just going to jump in and cherry you can
share you can keep on talking is that
you part of why we chose the film was
because we decide to work on is because
we knew we would have at lee in that
short time is that the Joffrey would was
kind of was on board and we could talk
to them because it would have been very
difficult to engage them had there not
been some three like that would have
been insane inthe also to know that the
Joffrey didn't make this film they
weren't involved in the production of
the film as far as paying for it or have
any financial stake in it so they didn't
have to partner with us they didn't have
to do they could see a reason why it
would be a good idea but we still had to
approach them and put together the case
and all that stuff because they didn't
they weren't financing it or anything
you have to convince even the people
that you think don't need to be
convinced I mean everyone people are
busy like they've got so many other
things to do with their lives that even
if they're you know people are busy you
have to make compelling cases for people
to work with you yeah and I wish we
could talk more about the Joffrey
because it is such a great film and I
think even people that aren't dance
enthusiasts would love it because it
really talks about sort of finding a
family outside of your own and all that
i wish i wish i'm gonna take that pull
quote that's going in the present kick
we like it you're like you they'll
encourage of sherry sherry forgive us we
have to cut it short forgive us we're
gonna have to pick it up with you two in
our afterlife here we're gonna have to
talk a little bit more about Joffrey we
just there's so much ground one to cover
we did our best is really badly show
contain you too but there's no there's
no hair love don't bottling you two up
and we just some yeah we can see why
while we've had two here on the show
repeatedly yeah this is sad I don't want
to stop doing this here but it yeah yeah
figures are our last challenge where we
can't stop we were so we're trying to
keep it going but we have to cut it to a
close we do so we've been speaking with
sherry candler John Reese for more on
sherry and John please visit john reese
calm sherry Kendler calm Joffrey movie
calm and hybrid cinema net Joffrey
Mavericks of American dance limited
edition DVD is now on sale yeah
it can be purchased by visiting Joffrey
movie calm and we'd like to thank our
guy Ronan Rosner he's the guy you seldom
see or hear but he plays a huge part in
what we do once again we would like to
thank Sam and Dina and the entire la
talk radio family and if you have a
radio show that you would like to
produce please contact sam hacen out la
talk radio com